here's a spoiler for you try as you
might you can't please everyone it's
something that Game of Thrones
showrunners David Benioff and DB Weiss
have learned the hard way as the final
season of the pop culture phenomenon has
infuriated and disappointed legions of
fans and critics around the world in
fact so many people were upset by the
final season that over a million viewers
signed an online petition calling for
HBO to remake all six episodes with
different storylines and a new team of
writers so what does the cast of Game of
Thrones think about all this well Isaac
Hempstead right who plays the newest
king of Westeros bran stark told The
Hollywood Reporter that he for one
thought the petition was absurd I saw
today there's a petition to redo the
ending it's just absurd I can't even
fathom it it's ridiculous that people
think they can just demand a different
ending because they don't like it
Hempstead right admitted that he took
the petition personally in part because
he just doesn't agree with people who
think the final season was bad what
people were hoping for is an Avengers
esque thing where all the superpowers
are explained and everybody comes
together and there's a big team effort
Game of Thrones isn't like that it's
unpredictable by nature in my opinion
it's a great ending I don't think it's
some plot twist to be shocking for the
sake of shocking I think it's a genuine
character development in fact he thinks
people getting angry at the ending is
just further proof of how good the show
was the fact that characters are not
doing what people want them to do it's a
good thing the fact that people are
getting pissed off and having a big
emotional response that's the reason why
Game of Thrones is successful it doesn't
do what everyone wants them to do of
course the interview with Hempstead
right was published before the season
finale aired on Sunday May 19th at the
time the petition was created fans were
still infuriated over the events of the
show's penultimate episode the bells
which saw fan favorite Daenerys
Targaryen go completely mental and mass
murder tens if not hundreds of thousands
of people for what seemed like no good
reason the finale though has by and
large received kinder critical and fan
reviews though it didn't fully satisfy
everyone the death of Daenerys at Jon
Snow's hand and the subsequent crowning
of brand the three-eyed Raven as king of
the six kingdoms was met with more
resigned shrugs than blinding rage and
at least Benioff and Weiss wrote and
directed the finale than
making sure that the final
responsibility for bringing the series
home rested on the right shoulders after
all his Ned taught bran way back in the
series premiere the man who passes the
sentence should swing the sword so while
it's true that few fans got everything
they wanted out of the finale the fact
that nobody's completely satisfied might
actually be a good thing
just ask Tyrion no one is very happy
which means it's a good compromise as it
is indeed the last episode of Game of
Thrones took some interesting turns and
placed power into the hands of a few
unexpected people it also gave the
members of the stark family a relatively
happy ending something nobody could have
expected after all the losses they
suffered in previous seasons and the
divisive final season doesn't change the
fact that so many people genuinely loved
the show or that Thrones will go down in
history as one of the most popular
television series of this generation as
the new king of Westeros said if people
really really hate this season then so
be it
but it's been seven or eight years of
absolutely brilliant television that
captivated the world I think people will
remember it as a fabulous journey to
have been a part of no matter their
opinion on the ending check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]